I had this rule with my old man and I
have it with my son which is when you're
fishing you can swear and the fin pokes
him in the hand falls in the water he
starts to cry he said Oh dad I'm about
to swear hey you know you know the rules
and he goes that bass that bass is
stupid I love that and that is so real
it's perfect yes now Chris Pratt of
course loves a good challenge whether
it's fishing or American Ninja Warrior
he is one of the show's biggest
celebrity fans so you know that he's
gonna be watching tonight I'm a single
mom I make no excuses we got new
competitors 19 years old we've lowered
the age requirement so it's gonna be one
big clash for supremacy of who's gonna
be the next American Ninja Warrior the
competition is always fierce the fails
are brutal and exciting to watch but the
first reason we love American Ninja
Warrior the inspiring comeback stories
when I was diagnosed with cancer I was
just devastated I went from not being
able to uh to being able to compete on
American Ninja Warrior
we were living out of the car it is an
opportunity to show my kids how to live
life and to not give up
the second reason kids love the show all
across the country parents are making
mini ninja courses hashtag strength
course families are buying courses for
their backyards and having birthday
parties and I think that the fans are
really driving the show whoa I got to
try the course now I only trained for
four hours but let me tell you to be a
Ninja Warrior
you've got to be ready for the pain
and that was some entertainment tonight
during season 10 which premieres tonight
we'll see celebs including Chris Pratt
and Bryce Dallas Howard on the show and
that's reason three stars are big fans
of the competition - we've seen Derek
Hough on a ferris allison janney
but who should be next honestly I would
love to see Ryan Reynolds the guy's
remarkably fit and he's hilarious on
Deadpool I don't want to hear about Ryan
Reynolds I want to know about one guy
cameraman oh you going back I have been
training but I didn't get the info
no invite y'all scared
[Music]
[Applause]